welcome to this video round 2 coverage
of the candidates tournament in
countyman disc and the game we look at
now in this video is Sevilla against I
draken both players have made a draw in
the first round swidler in a relatively
interesting game they could have her
continued at the end but decided to call
it today with a really weird repetition
so when I was content with a draw us
black against kayak and fine and that
dragon decided to play a long book line
long preparation heavy line that
basically guaranteed him a draw against
kramnik with the white pieces and yeah
therefore they both have half point
after round one so let's see what
happens yes we learn opening with a form
yeah his main move but in the last
couple of years swidler has branched out
he has played d4 Knight f3 everything
common trend among top players to be
versatile and that dragon is up for a
surprise he plays this line which in
conjunction with d6 nowadays by far the
main move I'm is called the Kalashnikov
variation not quite sure why this is one
of those unsolved named mysteries and
chests no one really knows why it is
called the Kalashnikov um yeah certainly
a surprise I checked it he has never
played before under akin so spill
certainly could not expect this line
yeah it is a near relative of the schwa
schnee cough and can dispose and in some
cases and of course I'm so of course
this line has been basically
yeah put on the on the city put on the
scene by / Nick off it's a second big
invention and then in the opening on did
this was known for me yes but resnikoff
really a made it an interesting opening
um it's a very similar but has some
different features and one we see
immediately spill after some thought he
was surprised played c4 white has a
principal choice he can play with c4 or
without c4 c4 of course makes sure that
black is never ever going to play d65 or
let's say need very very rare cases so
it's firm locate of the pond but it also
of course makes this Bishop look
somewhat dubious as it is very often in
this maroc see bind c44 type of
positions the bishop is sometimes a
problem piece on the other hand of
course it's a very good central control
the main alternative is mentioned is
night of one to see 3 more like peace
play approach here black can even
transpose to the trash Nick off if he
wants but the normal idea is to go like
that b5 is not mandatory but usually
played 95 and now black can play a
various moves Knight f6 um night here
it's it's like the situation cough but
not quite so an interesting variation as
well for white was with 93 but okay c4
is played is Bishop e7 first 93 and now
we have the night cm on a three and c3
this is of course also why this type of
setup in the Sicilian often is
attractive for black white loses many
moves with this night
f 3d form b 5 a 3 possibly here here and
so on these are many moves and black
only has made useful moves in the
meantime in general this structure for
black it's not it's not unhealthy at all
especially considering that he gets him
put this moves on the board he gets this
Bishop which is notoriously bad looking
at the own pawns he gets this exchange
quickly against White's structurally
speaking good Bishop and therefore only
retreat retains after this capture only
retains I'm strategically speaking good
pieces he has two nights in a relatively
close position useful pieces and he has
got this useful Bishop which also
controls on looks at the point in d5
square wide on the other hand has the
space advantage connected with this
typical maroc see bind pawns and he can
even on build up on that with the
further before we see that later in the
game so white is space but on the other
hand he's got a potentially problematic
bishop this is not so important when you
have a space advantage Bishop which is
often called a bad bishop because it's
on on light square some light square
Bishop slight SquarePants this is not so
much your problems if you have the space
then the structurally bad bishop is
often getting a problem only if you also
suffer from lack of space like it is
sometimes happening in the French
defense where widely enjoys a big space
advantage of you in addition you have
this maybe sometimes clumsy bishop on c8
and this can get a problem but here what
the bishop is not such a big deal in the
long run however it might become tricky
this piece so something that white needs
to watch out for now under aching played
Queen g5
and I of course I looked this up in the
database to somehow judge this this
opening selection and this is a somewhat
rare move it seems experts of this line
I'm usually prefer a night move here by
Knight f6 or sometimes knight to e7 I
actually like Knight f6 here and I'm not
so sure about this Queen g5 muth it
looks active of course putting the Queen
out on g5 but i don't really know i feel
that the plane is going to mostly happen
on the queenside and i'm unsure that the
queen is really well placed on g5 for
any Queen side action it's not offside
I'm not saying that but I say normally
yeah let's let's just look at at
something look at this this is the
normal way how this is continued and
here black place the Queen to be 6 and
then place a look d aid group c 8 and
compared to the game i just prefer that
I think the queen is better placed on
the queenside you can also we treat to
a7 if it filled sir it feels
uncomfortable on b6 but it looks at
critical squares the screen while on g5
it's not so clear what it is doing let's
let's check the game in comparison plate
25 swidler again was a bit surprised it
took them took 10 minutes to castle rock
d 8 this is another problem now you have
to play whoop dat sd-6 hanging and white
is going to take it if you play them for
like 90 of 6 I will take it and you
cannot castle so root dat needed to
needs to be played and this means that
after before which technically is a
novelty by the way
there was only a couple of games played
with that position and it wasn't like
why'd ya there weren't many very strong
GMS s white they normally played 95
which is not bad at all but before
fields feels right to me white probably
does not want to commit so early to any
night jump to d5 where it might get get
taken you can easily build up first play
before play three Queen here group here
you have many approving moves this is
also one slight problem with black
structure in this position it's a
structure that is mostly get towards
reacting to White's ideas and try to
yeah sort of be solid and then play for
counter counter attacks it's not like
black can do so much in terms of getting
active himself and this is yeah not very
comfortable to play we see that after
before dragging played Knight f6 23
castles wrote you on all perfectly
logical moves and yeah what are you
going to do now is black yeah I note
that it is quite comparable to the
position that we saw before but there
the Queen was on b6 and the rooks we're
on da 10 c 8 and this just feels yeah I
don't know more harmonious to me the
setup not not sure what like should do
he played a look to see eight trying to
correct the placement of the rooks so
get rook FD Aidan wyd now played 95 he
has played almost all essential
defensive moves yeah and here um I'm not
sure I think black probably should just
play let's say look the
82 complete the setup and what I believe
is somewhat better slightly better after
yeah many moves you can consider that
it's not bad let's say let's do that
type B 6 lube plate and let's say a 3
just yeah improving the structure and we
have a position where black has very
little play he can you can try some
action on the Kings side to somehow
justify the Queen position let's say age
5 try something like that but you're
never going to get a meeting attack here
this is very unlikely and in general I
think why this slightly more comfortable
here but I do believe that this is
better than the game in the game and do
I can try to do something active and it
didn't really work out after some
consideration he played be five active
move but it's i don't i don't really
like it I mean that would really like it
and villas reply it's really strong now
very strong move I believe he played the
Queen to g3 now and this is just for for
concrete technical reasons a good move
of course it it forces thanks why
there's simply threatening to take the
Queen black must do something in regards
to the to the Queen and what he did is
he took on g3 I was also looking at
Knight takes e4 also i moved to consider
why then has a good reply i believe in
the capture and night to be six and this
turns out to be a really tricky now for
black this is hanging on d5 of course
and the rook are saying so let's say
look to be eight after that white has
this idea a rook takes d6 in order to
answer the capture with c5 quite funny
and white will get material back
this is a very interesting line which
can be continued like that 94 groupie
six every six kegs on b6 and after all
this fireworks we have reached a
position where actually material is
equal but white enjoys this strong pole
on b6 might get support with this now
also an ID move of course to let the
rook join the game wyd i believe is is
better and this is just one sample line
white has in fact even alternatives to
that he decided however to take on g3
immediately black did and now White has
very strong intermediate move course man
takes f6 check there from black must
capture and now why takes and it turns
out that this position is quite
uncomfortable for black it's simply for
one reason black has made many poor
moves that have left weaknesses behind
all those poor all those pawns are weak
and in comparison why does not have such
clear weaknesses that can be attacked
and he has somewhat better peace
deployment the rooks are both playing
but black is lacking a move if black
would have the rukon d8 already for
example it would probably be perfectly
right but the way it is now it's it's
really a not comfortable to play at all
he took them on c4 with the pawn we can
look at oops was too much we can look at
alternatives let's say Bishop takes
after that white captures and takes on
t6 yeah and we see that it's really
uncomfortable black has this pawn
attacked and yeah what should
if it keeps it let's say King to g7
white will play the instant reply 93
with the idea to go for night f5 check
and this is another problem of course of
this somewhat wrecked pawn structure the
f5 square a black has no way to prevent
prevent the night from coming to the
square a move like 97 is mostly
pointless due to the capture and know
that why does upon up this is almost
lost 10 and so on so King g7 is not even
halfway playable so rook the eight need
to be active film look f6 King g7 is not
not so so great probably so y term
should go for something else you can
however simply take and this is better
rook takes the eight group takes the
eight and 93 after night before a 396
Rob c4 we reach a position where white
simply has an excellent ending with the
prospects of yeah torturing the black
player for four hours this is just a
very bad from structural point of view
full of weaknesses even the a6 pawn is
somewhat weaker than they three Pawn
just because of the more active piece
configuration um yeah that's a very very
bad end game from black very awkward in
the game he decided to take with the
porn not with the bishop and after f4
again strong move not difficult but
simple and strong after F for now black
ass in real trouble f5 is the idea one
idea and so that's of course d6 hanging
he could have taken that immediately but
f-for now is stronger black only has the
the choice between various worst
positions now
let's say he covers d6 for argument's
sake then white has f5 and Bishop k XC 4
and this is just a very comfortable
position two pawns against one white as
a potential passer on the queenside he
has control over d 5 and black still
suffers from all those weaknesses so
it's an a very unpleasant sight this
position for black he tried to defend a
more actively played f5 Drake ended and
here swidler just took played 93 gaining
a temple on the bishop yet here black
actually only has one move to UM to
really continue the game he needs to
play a bishop reform relatively active
move centralizing the bishop it's not
like it's much fun to play that but it's
simply the only way to to continue the
possible line is rook d6 night eggs on
before here this captures then let's say
something something like that ISM as a
possible line and yeah that's not much
fun something like that what is just
better coordinated those pieces are just
better than blacks counterparts this is
very weak on f7 like we'll get another
another piece
that will check f7 soon Whitehead has
the better King and so on and so on
probably a five will also fall note that
the a2 porn is always easily protected
by the bishop when a 5 has does not have
a comparable defense so very
uncomfortable but black can can continue
to struggle he played Bishop d3 though
and this seems to to lose instantly why
takes let's be glad he also played it
and now plate night f5 and we relatively
quickly sense what the problem was with
this line white now has the idea to take
on d6 and also to take on c6 utilizing
this fork so a black place just to show
the threat nothing move white completely
useless of course white can take check
and this way when the piece so this is
an additional problem white threatens
here and here so I'm tough too tough to
defend I mean wrong word impossible to
defend um what should like do if it
tries to get out of this possible fork
let's say when King h8 then the second
threat kicks into effect attacking the
rook and you try to save that just play
a 4 b5 and win the night it's as simple
as that it's simply too bad this
position if black plays route g8 for
example there's roop c6 it's just it's
just too much check oops and winning it
back with the totally totally one
position ya black ass in fact out of out
of museum it's no way to to to fight
actually he tried a form using you
using the pawns and trying to make it as
difficult as possible interestingly
enough sweet Allah here took on d6 and
not on c6 he could have won the peace
it's possible yeah like that but he
didn't do that I suspect that after rook
c8 90 for this position was not one
hundred percent clear to him maybe black
might be able to approach with the king
or invade here can only speculate and
this also seems winning for white but he
probably thought that his lioness cesis
more convincing and in fact it may be is
it is rarely relatively easy to see what
he did and it seems to be winning
totally he took on nerdy six young and
now black tried the only yeah possible
play played III young if black moves the
rook to c7 I'll just stay here for and
it did it it starts to get ya even o+
form of your material account like place
i Luke the eighth here to save d3 i'm
just going to support my stuff um and
pick up with moves like that pick up the
deep on it just totally lost what also
already has an extra porn and d3 will be
one yeah he tried III just for ya for
last hope counter play yeah Knight takes
Yates witla just takes it all and this
is the easiest way to play yeah now of
course black needs to push the pawns you
cannot recapture here white will just
take the three and it's very easy so he
pushed d to route takes c6 and e2 is
quite funny
don't see that too often after 27 moves
black has managed to put a push both as
central pawns to the second rank but
okay bye now White has so much material
you can play the funny defense rook C 2
C 1 and yeah it's just it's just funny
both rooks I hanging but yeah famously
said you can only take one piece at a
time like cannot take both looks which
would be nice of course he can only take
one of them and yeah he decided to take
on a g1 of course with the under
promotion if you have the chance you
should do that he took on d1 and got the
rook rook takes e1 rook c8 and rooty to
this was what's wit tha had calculated
when he took on d6 instead of rook takes
c6 he saw that he will get this rook
endgame and this is in fact a very easy
win why it has two extra pawns this
means that he has a potential passer on
the queenside he also has an extra porn
on the King side and this is just too
much for for black to defend he only
played a couple of more groups III group
d 50 event only ones after rook t5 here
he resigned and simply also because Luke
a5 will attack the pawn on a six and
false black into a very passive defense
and then it is it's very easy to to win
it's also it's simply that the on the
kingside white is also in an
overwhelming position if you see that
like rook c 6-r ooh k 5 I just put it on
the board you had this kind of this kind
of thing this is like complete control
black cannot move the pawns and then you
just improve the king and so on and so
on at the end you can also get this this
rolling it's just very useful to have
a dominant position on the King side as
well so that you can easily yes which
the cause of the action and also attack
on the kingside this is some just too
much in this and this end game so under
akin resigned and this makes some this
tournament very tough for him here with
this early early loss against swidler
who has called an important win to get a
good start in this tournaments will have
played a really good game him he made he
he took some very very good decisions I
think that Queen g3 was strong very
strong booth and very decisive very
decisive the plate or in size of Leith
may be the right word and also a former
strong it's not very difficult but all
this had a very a very good natural flow
and he I think he played almost
consistently the top move of the engine
not that I'm accusing anything here I'm
just saying that it's perfectly possible
to find the move there's nothing in
human or machine like about them is just
very precise and then good play so yeah
good start for sweetland and a good game
to watch this is I think and set up that
you can recommend against this opening
for very safe position on as white where
you can try for thumb something without
really risking too much all right I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching